>> [Music playing]
>> It's a big, big question.
Not easy.
>> So the Davos question has been asked.
>> Hello, Davos people.
>> The Davos question --
>> Davos question.
>> [Speaking in foreign language]
>> Today I would like to mention this Davos
question.
>> The Davos question.
>> I'd like to answer --
>> The Davos question
>> The Davos question.
>> I'm replying to the Davos question.
>> What one thing --
>> -- Do you think --
>> -- That countries --
>> -- Companies --
>> -- Or individuals must do --
>> -- To make the world --
>> -- A better place --
>> -- In 2008?
>> There's different countries, different
companies, and different
individuals.
So I don't know about 6 billion or something.
6 billion with a "b".
This is kinda difficult because everyone's
gonna have different
answers.
>> [People talking all at once]
>> Loads, and loads, and loads, and loads
of different answer because
everyone got their own individual perspective
of how they see things
and how they see the world.
>> We need to find a way to stop the poverty
rate from going up and
make it go down!
>> Why does our world not have a safe blood
supply?
>> Covering the globe with, uh, high speed
two-way.
That's where we gotta go.
>> Invest in kids.
>> Water shortage will be a key challenge
facing the world in the
first half of the twenty-first century.
>> By investing in renewable energy, perhaps
we can save many of the
species that are dying because of the impact
we cause to the
environment but more importantly we will also
avoid struggles and war,
and is that not what we want for our children?
A world in which we can work together in peace?
>> As a writer, as a human being, I think
that everybody in the world
is commited to improve the state of the world.
>> We have to be able to communicate the best
that we can from
generation to generation, and build upon the
past, and improve upon
the past.
>> Try to open your mind to what other people
are saying and let's
share our ideas and let's progress.
>> [Music playing]